[Music]
[Music]
after a weekend of hype at the tokyo
game show we
once again return to the hero's path a
series in which we visualize the
different journeys of some of the most
prominent characters from breath of the
wild
during the great calamity as expected
the team at cuy tecmo didn't spoil too
much in terms of story
showing only gameplay sections taking
place pre-calamity
and even the trailer kept things quite
abstract we did however get to see empi
in action
and were presented with a bit more of an
idea about her role in the story
which is perfect for this episode in
today's topic we will cover the three
most prominent members of the chica
tribe
that being impa herself her sister and
sheikah scientist pura
and ancient technology expert robbie all
of which are still alive during the
events of breath of the wild albeit
older or in poorest case younger
depending on how you look at it
joining me in today's episode is my
fellow countrymen and veteran zelda
theorists dr wily
make sure to head over to his channel
after you're done watching this video
as he has a lot to offer not just on the
subject of zelda but also mario amongst
other topics
now the final two episodes in this
series are going to be a bit different
than the previous ones
unlike zelda link and the other four
champions we don't actually have a path
laid out for any of these characters in
creating a champion
so these journeys will be based on that
which we do know
the most prominent zelda theories as
well as just best guesses in general so
take these paths with a grain of salt
with that out of the way
let's jump right back into it
so since we don't have a definitive path
for the sheikah during the calamity
we first have to establish the starting
point for each character
which we can base on various bits of
information robbie and pura are the
easiest to pinpoint
all research into the guardians and
other ancient sheikah relics
was performed at hyrule castle both the
akala and the clude attack labs were not
established until
after the calamity was over the heart of
controlling the ancient relics and
storing the data collected lies in the
guidance stones
of which a significant amount were also
being kept at the castle
this means that both pura and robbie
were most likely at the castle the
moment the calamity started
they may have even set up a temporary
home in this area
since research was done on a daily basis
and would have saved a lot of time
traveling from kakariko village to the
castle
every day this is further supported by
the following sentence
found in creating a champion on the day
of the great calamity the surviving
sheikah from the castle in hyrule castle
town
fled to their hometown of kakariko
village this indicates that some shika
did indeed live in the main capital of
the hylians
ampura and robbie were most likely among
those who did
impasse a bit trickier though since she
herself was not directly involved in the
research as far as we know
and instead acted as the official
advisor to the royal family
being an advisor doesn't necessarily
mean she would have to be at the castle
at all times
or even live there like the others and
in the new age of calamity gameplay
and trailer we can see that she tagged
along with link and his group for quite
a bit
throughout the events preceding the
calamity on the day of ganon's rise
however
she's not present at the landeru
promenade to meet with zelda
after her pilgrimage to the spring of
wisdom this leaves us with two
options in regards to her most likely
location
either she's at the castle with her
sister and robbie or she is at her
hometown kakariko village
waiting for a party to return from the
promenade now for the sake of pacing
we're just going to pick one of these
locations as a starting point
there's no evidence for or against both
options
and it doesn't really impact the overall
arc of the story too much
so we are going with kakariko village
for this theory
for reasons mentioned earlier as well as
the fact that in age of calamity she's
seen tagging along with
link and zelda at harold castle during
the calamity
sure they could have met up at the
castle but on the other hand
meeting one specific person amidst all
the chaos would undoubtedly be
very difficult so it's safe to assume
that she joined them to the castle from
kakariko
with the position of all characters now
set we can finally start outlining their
paths from the moment the calamity
starts
after zelda and the five champions
witness the rise of ganon
they make their way through to promenade
and towards kakariko
there they rendezvous with impa who tags
along with link and zelda towards hyrule
castle
impa has all the reasons to join them as
she will want to ensure the safety of
her sister pura and other fellow shika
who reside at the castle
they traverse the same path laid out in
the section that covers lincoln zelda
down sahasrara's slope following the
haila river north
across the rabone bridge mabe prairie
and into castle town
through the main gate by the time they
arrive the guardians have been corrupted
and hiro castle itself has turned into
absolute chaos
as mentioned in the story of link and
zelda it's likely that the events at
hyrule castle town will be a playable
section
where the princess hero and empire try
to fight off as many guardians as
possible
they may even make their way up to
hyrule castle itself an age of calamity
does seem to show sections where they
actually are at the castle and not just
a town square
for zelda the main motivation would of
course be to confront ganon himself as
well as find her father king rome who
resides somewhere amidst all the turmoil
going on there
but for impa the main goal would be to
locate her sister pura and her friend
robbie who were likely at the castle
doing their daily dose of research when
disaster struck
this potential playable section up to
hyrule castle might be an actual rescue
mission to attempt to save their loved
ones
impa manages to meet up with pura robbie
and any other surviving shika members
after realizing that hyrule castle and
town are beyond saving and with the area
flooding with more and more guardians
impa urges link and zelda to meet up at
kakariko village and discuss a new
strategy from there
at this point getting as many people to
safety is the main objective
since zelda still hasn't managed to
awaken her power and thus confronting
ganon is futile
with little time to linger impa pura and
robbie gather up as much of the ancient
relics as possible
in an attempt to salvage it for future
use this includes parts of two
guidance stones the very same we find at
the nacluda and akala tech labs in
breath of the wild
from here they would likely make their
escape through the east gate of
castletown
through the romani plains apleian forest
and across the rebony bridge
they then move south along the hylia
river up the sahasrara slope and into
kakariko village though their journey
towards kakariko is a dangerous one
jashika are not the prime target of
ganon's army
that would be link and zelda this would
explain what i managed to reach for
boney bridge ahead of link and zelda
as by the time the hero and princess
reach the bridge it's no longer safe to
cross
and they would have to move south
alongside the other side of the hylian
river
although not being the main target the
sheikah's escape route could still be a
playable section
where impan needs to defend the
scientists and other potential survivors
from any guardians in pursuit of them or
monster hordes obstructing their way
forward as of yet we don't know who the
other playable characters in age of
calamity will be
but since she is accompanied by robbie
and pura one of them might be playable
as well
impasse seems to be the fighter of the
group but there are passages in robbie's
memoirs
that describe him as someone who would
dispose of guardians himself
in a one-on-one situation when he was
younger however
it remains to be seen if either him or
pora will be doing any fighting
since they are scientists first after
all all in all it is safe to say that
the sheikah's escape from hyrule castle
to kakariko was an important one
as the preservation of some of the
ancient technology will prove to be
crucial
in the future now after reaching
kakariko the shika survivors hold up at
the village and nervously await the
arrival of princess zelda
after she fails to show up the worried
impa dispatches various chica warriors
to track her down
creating a champion makes it abundantly
clear that kakariko village was never
touched by the guardians
the natural border of mountains
surrounding the village as well as the
fact that the sheikahs were not ganon's
main focus
kept the village polluted and out of
harm's way but
as we have seen with gerudo town and
recently with goron village in the
latest gameplay demonstrations of age of
calamity
there's always still a possibility of
kakariko village
having to deal with monster attacks this
would grant the option for impa to have
one final gameplay
section where she has to keep her
hometown safe from any potential
invaders
as from this point on her role in the
story as a fighter
would basically end since as far as we
know
impa never left kakariko beyond this
point in the story
in the meantime two of the shika
warriors dispatched by impa locate the
princess and the hero in the fields of
platory plain
in front of fort titano while they carry
the mortally wounded link to the shrine
of resurrection
along with the sheikah side zelda
finally meets up with impa
at the village after discussing a new
strategy zelda continues on her journey
to hyrule's great forest alone to return
the master sword
and face calamity ganon however impa
instructs
robbie and pora to make their way to the
shrine of resurrection
located on the great plateau to assist
in operating the facility
although we don't have any information
on how exactly pura and robbie got from
kakariko to the great plateau the most
likely scenario would be that they
follow the same path as the two shika
warriors carrying link to the facility
with most of the guardians at fort
hatteno disposed of by zelda it is by
far the safest route to take
they move across the road next the
blattery plane and follow the path in
between the duelling peaks
past their village and across the proxim
bridge from there they crossed the
ruined outpost located at the foot of
the plateau and up to the shrine of
resurrection
by this point central hyrule has long
since fallen and the battles here are
over
most of the remaining guardians have
likely moved out of the province in
search for more blood in the surrounding
areas
such as the gerudo province tabantha
region across the bridge of hailia into
the farron region
la and akala this would have granted
link as well as pura and robbie a safer
passage onto the plateau
there might be a small chance that this
journey towards the shrine of
resurrection taken by pura and robbie is
playable
however out of all scenarios presented
this is by far the most unlikely one
we have no idea if either of the two
characters will even be playable first
of all
and second in this point of the story
the main focus would obviously be on
zelda's journey
still we wanted to at least mention the
possibility before finishing up this
episode
as this will be the last gameplay
scenario presented from this moment on
we pretty much know how the story ends
link is laid to rest by pura and robbie
and impa remains in kakariko village
while zelda finally ends the war by
sealing the demon king inside the castle
with ganon now sealed the remaining
guardians and four divine beasts
no longer pose an immediate threat
though the guardians still remain
dangerous if approached they have turned
into mindless drones who roamed the
landscape without coordination or
purpose
after the two shika scientists return to
kakariko village
robbie pura and impa decide to separate
and live their lives in different parts
of hyrule far away from each other
this way they increase the chance that
at least one of them will be alive to
meet with link once he finally wakes up
and assists him on his journey
in the years to come impa becomes chief
of kakariko village while pura and ravi
set up their respective tech labs in the
cluda and akala
pura continues her research into the
ancient chica relics using one of the
guidance stones they managed to salvage
from hyrule castle
and with his modified guidance stone
robbie manages to develop the ancient
arrow the first weapon to be effective
against guardians
some say that this was his way of
atoning for his deepest regret of not
being able to provide
link with the weapons effective against
the guardians on the day of the great
calamity
though his discoveries came decades too
late his inventions will still prove to
be useful when link
finally makes his inevitable return for
the next 100 years since the day of the
great calamity
the three patiently await the return of
the hero
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you